for a daily cancellation today we are
cancelling the daily cancellation just
for the day so that I could talk about
something uh a bit more serious
yesterday we discussed the story of the
leftist activist in Philadelphia who was
murdered in his home after spending the
previous several years aggressively
downplaying the violent crime problem in
his City and he mocked those who pointed
out that Philadelphia had become a crime
ridden Wasteland and then he himself
ultimately fell victim to the problem
that he denied so it turns out that
reality still exists and will assert
itself even if you have your head firmly
planted in the sand and that was in
Philadelphia now we have a story out of
New York with some very similar themes
the post millennial reports a stabbing
took place early Monday morning in
Brooklyn's Bedford uh St vescent
neighborhood claiming the life of poet
and far-left activist Ryan Carson the
32-year-old was walking down the
sidewalk with his girlfriend when he was
attacked by a stranger a video emerged
of the incident it shows the couple
sitting on a bench on the sidewalk when
a man wa walks past them in a black
hoodie the man crosses the street walks
half half a block down then begins
kicking over scooters in the street the
couple rise and walk in the same
direction when the man turns around and
approaches the couple the couple
continue walking toward him a
confrontation ensues where in Carson
puts up his hands and seems to attempt
to dispel the tension the man gets
closer to him and Carson pushes him off
surveillance footage cuts to after the
stabbing with Carson on the ground and
his girlfriend standing by him the
attacker makes a motion toward her as
well before moving off according to New
York Post the incident took place
shortly before 4:00 a.m. on Monday um
just uh near a bus stop okay so there is
a video it says of the incident I'm not
going to play the part where carison is
actually stabbed to death no reason for
anyone to watch that but I want you to
see everything that led up to uh this
murder
[Applause]
watch
right
now chill
chill
I'm so sorry are you a are you please
please go watch him go watch
him now this is obviously very sad to
see it's tragic anytime a deranged
violent useless social parasite who's
been left to roam the streets by our
even more useless justice system
randomly murder someone it's obviously
always a terrible thing and also we
should acknowledge that Carson appears
in that video to place himself between
the crazy guy and his girlfriend
potentially saving her life in the
process and that takes real courage so
it's not for the sake of uh of of
gloating obviously that we point out
that Carson was not only a far-left
activist but according to reporting from
Andy no was a self-described antifa
member and his girlfriend no reports had
previously posted anti-cop sentiments
writing that uh the police do not
protect you along with aab and
BLM now these details are relevant not
because we want to dunk over a body but
because there are very important lessons
that must be learned in order to prevent
this sort of thing from happening in the
future so let's review this first of all
Ryan and his uh girlfriend are out
walking the streets of Brooklyn at 400
a.m. now I don't know what they were
doing out there or why they were out
there The Daily Mail claims that they
were waiting for a bus but in the video
you can see them getting up from the
bench and walking away from it towards
someplace else but even if they were
even if they were taking the bus either
way you don't walk in the city at 4:00
a.m. and you don't take public
transportation in the city at 4:00 a.m.
um everything is more dangerous after
dark in the city and every person you
encounter has a greater likelihood of
doing you harm that's not paranoia it's
just the reality so mistake number one
was being there in the first place
second he sees the lone black male in a
hoodie walk by at 4:00 a.m. and he and
his girlfriend immediately get up and
walk the same
direction they don't even wait for a few
minutes to let him pass and put some
distance in between them they decide to
head his Direction when they're 20 ft
away from him they don't cross the
street as they should have done they
don't turn and walk the other way which
also would have been a better choice
they they walk right towards him which
was mistake number two and third when
the guy goes crazy and starts knocking
over Scooters or whatever he was doing
Carson continues to walk towards the
commotion and when the crazy guy notices
them and starts screaming at them Carson
tries to engage telling him to chill as
if he had any chance of calming a knife
wielding psycho who's going berserk on a
street corner in the middle of the night
and as soon as the crazy guy started
yelling at Carson saying what are you
looking at and you know Etc um Carson
still could have probably escaped with
his life if he had simply turned and
crossed the street and and don't stop
making eye contact just go the other way
and gotten himself and his girlfriend
out of the situation but he didn't do
that now there's a whole list of common
sense judgment calls Carson could have
made but he didn't and now tragically
he's dead because of it this is where
his status as a far-left activist comes
into play not for making fun of him but
for potentially understanding why he
made this series of glaring easily
avoidable errors now we cannot know for
sure what was in his head at the time
but we do know that leftist ideology
will not allow its adherents to make
Common Sense judgment calls because
those judgment calls are based on
stereotypes according to Carson's
ideology it would make him racist to
cross the street and avoid that
interaction it would be judgmental it
would be marginalizing it would be
otherizing leftist ideology would rather
that you be
killed than you make those kinds of
assumptions even if your assumptions are
statistically Justified especially if
they're statistically Justified leftist
ideology says it it's better to die than
that and Ryan Carson did Grant Ken
University is an affordable private
Christian University that is located in
beautiful Phoenix Arizona and has a
vibrant and expansive campus ranked top
20 in the country according to niche.com
praise for its culture of community
giving and impact GCU integrates the
free market system and a welcoming
Christian worldview Perspective into
over 320 academic programs with more
than 260 programs online as of March
2023 earn your bachelor's Masters or
doctoral degree where you can engage
with faculty and connect with your own
University counselor who takes a
personalized approach for your success
find your purpose at Grand Canyon
University private Christian affordable
visit gcu.edu that's gcu.edu now this
has become a major problem as human
beings we should have an innate ability
to calculate risk recognize patterns and
assess potential hazards and and most of
this should be automatic almost
unconscious this basic level of
situational awareness it's what keeps
you alive but leftism has been working
for years to interfere with that process
to to kind of short circuit that
hardwired programming that we all have
and to negate our ability to run these
kinds of
Assessments in fact the whole mental
process I just described in their
religion the religion of leftism leftism
is called unconscious bias and implicit
bias and it's something that they
say we should actively
reject you know according to leftism
when our gut says that guy looks
dangerous or don't walk that way or this
seems kind kind of sketchy we're being
driven by the racism embedded deeply in
our subconscious and we should ignore it
you know the proper response they say is
to ignore what our gut is telling us and
charge
ahead and this is not this is not a
straw man like go up to any de
professional and ask them show them the
first part of that video before we get
to the stabbing and the guy going
crazy you got the two white guys on
white people on the bench lone black
male in a hoodie walks by 4:00 a.m. in
the
city uh and you know and ask any per one
who works in Dei would it be okay for
those two white people on the bench to
look at that guy and say you know I
think I'm going to go the other I'm
gonna cross the street they will all
tell you no no if you do that you're
racist now you have to decenter your
whiteness and dismantle white
supremacy even if it means ending up
bleeding to death on the
sidewalk now those of us whose Minds
have not been overtaken by the virus of
leftism we make these gut level risk
calculations all the time and we should
admit it because there's nothing wrong
with it in fact not there not only is
there nothing wrong with it but it's the
right thing to do so just as one of
hundreds of potential examples from my
own life and any reasonable person we
all have hundreds of examples so here's
just a recent one for me recently I was
out driving with my son at night uh
coming from somewhere to my house and uh
it wasn't very late but it was dark and
we needed gas so I pulled into a gas
station and before I stopped at a pump I
noticed a couple of guys hanging around
off to the side these were young black
males both in hoodies not pumping gas
apparent apparently not engaging in any
kind of legitimate gas station related
business now did I know for sure that
they were dangerous of course not they
weren't visibly committing any crimes
they weren't doing anything that
justified calling the police they were
just
there now maybe if I had pulled up to a
pump and gotten out of my vehicle they
would have come over to me and talked to
me about the Gospel of Jesus Christ
maybe they were out there fundraising
For the Nights of Columbus it's possible
anything is possible but the situation
didn't feel right to me I got a bad Vibe
I didn't like the way it all looked I
had my son in the car with me I'm not
taking any chances so I left and the
whole process of risk calculation took
about 10 seconds you pull in didn't even
stop the car pulled in and say I don't
like the look at this I'll go somewhere
else now did I make stereotypical
assumptions hell yes I did what else was
I going to do you can only work with the
information you have immediately
available was the Assumption based
entirely on Race no obviously not if I
had pulled in and seen a middle-aged
black woman at a pump putting gas in her
Camry or whatever I wouldn't have been
concerned so my calculation was taking
everything into account everything about
the situation the people everything many
different factors including how they
were dressed what they're doing the
context or in this case not doing as
they were not pumping gas but if I was a
leftist the point is then the fact that
they were black males would have
prevented me from running that risk
calculation at all I would have felt
guilty for making assumptions based on
stereotypes however grounded in reality
those stereotypes might be I would have
stopped the car I would have gotten out
and maybe everything would have been
fine or maybe I would have gotten
carjacked with my child in the back seat
like these are the risks that leftism
would have you
make now late last month a white female
Techo in Baltimore named pava leer was
brutally beaten and murdered inside her
apartment complex allegedly by someone
named Jason Dean Billingsley and Jason
Dean Billingsley is a black man with an
extensive rap sheet that includes
assault and rape and yet he was still
out on the streets of
course but how did Billingsley get into
the apartment complex well the doors are
secure and only residents can get inside
well according to investigators leair
opened the door for Billingsley and let
him into the building he said that he
forgot his key and she believed him or
pretended to and then uh after letting
him in she got into an elevator with
this ominous looking guy with neck
tattoos it's a guy with neck tattoos
trying to get into a well we assume is a
is a higher income uh apartment complex
because you got a CEO living there and
she sees this guy and says oh yeah he
looks like he lives here even though
clearly he
doesn't a short time later she was dead
on the roof her body wasn't discovered
for several days now we don't know Le's
politics but as a white female Tech CEO
in Baltimore we can probably assume that
she wasn't exactly the sort of person
who would walk around in a Maga
hat and so we can also safely assume
that a certain amount of white guilt led
her to open the door for this guy with
neck tattoos who who didn't have a key
for the building and then get in an
elevator with him she didn't want a
stereotype so instead she
died another tragedy and what makes it
all the more tragic is that it is all so
easily avoid
voidable all of it can be
avoided But first you have to free your
mind from
leftism thanks for checking out this
video if you'd like to listen to my full
podcast on the go you can check out the
Matt wall show on Apple podcast Spotify
or wherever you get your podcast